Ah la France, le pays de la gastronomie.
Avec ses saveurs, ses produits, ses vignes,
et surtout son savoir faire culinaire qui a vu émerger les plus grands chefs étoilés.
On imagine que les habitants de ce terroir du goût doivent être à la hauteur de cette réputation mondiale
en étant de vrai cordon bleu.
Al dente.
Alors j'sais pas vous, mais moi quand il s'agit de cuisiner...
bah cuisiner, c'est un gros mot, disons plutôt faire à manger...
rien ne marche.
Quand je fais cuire un truc, il y a tellement de fumée qu'on voit plus les meubles.
Quand je fais des poissons panés, la panure elle reste sur la poêle...
ça fait des poissons panés décapotés !
Quand je conserve de la nourriture au frigo, au bout d'une semaine j'ai créé une nouvelle forme de vie !
Quand je fais cuire un truc j'ai l'impression qu'il y a l'étape pas cuit,  puis l'étape brûlé.
Oh non, putain !
Quand je fais une pizza au four, elle traverse les barreaux.
Quand je casse un œuf, je passe ma vie à enlever les coquilles.
Quand je fais un truc surgelé au micro onde, c'est brûlant à l'extérieur et glacé à l'intérieur.
Utiliser une poêle égale détruire une poêle.
Et quand je fais bouillir de l'eau, bah en général je pars tellement longtemps que quand je reviens...
Bah il y a plus d'eau.
Il fait un peu humide ici hein ? C'est quoi, c'est un hammam ou.....
Moi, je ne sais pas faire à manger, c'est pas dans mes gènes.
Bon quand il y a des invités il y a quand même un truc que je connais, c'est...
Bah c'est Deliveroo et UberEats.
Après déjà, faut faire la différence entre
quand tu fais à manger pour plusieurs personnes, et quand tu fais à manger juste pour toi.
Ça tue !
Je sais pas. Prenons un truc simple, genre... cuire des trucs à la poêle !
Bah quand tu fais ça, y'a des petites giclées d'huile brûlante qui te sautent dessus !
Du coup, tu es comme un con à essayer des petites techniques :
La technique du bras le plus long possible.
Utiliser un objet extérieur.
- Eh, ça va !
Se protéger comme on peut...  Ta mere !!!
Ou carrément ma technique perso : bah éteindre le feu, retourner la viande, et rallumer le feu.
Je pense que je suis trop impatient pour cuisiner. Parce-que dès qu'il faut attendre un peu que ça cuise,
je me casse faire une autre activité,
pensant que je serai de retour à temps pour la cuisson.
Bon, là ça cuit, ça va durer environ 10 minutes.
*Musique angoissante*
*Rire* Ce kill était culte !
Ok les mecs, on enchaîne. Putain, la fumée du jeu est trop bien faite là !
Il y a une nouvelle mise à jour ou... ?
*Son du détecteur de fumée* Oh merde !
Il y a certains aliments, je veut même pas essayer de les faire.
Par ce que tu as beau aérer chez toi après,
tes vêtements et ta maison sont imprégnés de l'odeur.
*Renifle*
- WOOUH ! Toi t'as cuisiné des sardines, je me trompe ?
- Ouais ouais, c'est vrai, ouais. C'était en janvier...
il y a deux mois.
C'est dur de respecter une recette parce que, soit j'ai jamais les ingrédients qu'il faut,
ou soit je me sens plus et j'en rajoute comme si ça allait rien changer.
Oh merde, j'ai que deux œufs ! Bon aller, ça passe. Il faut du lait.
Bon j'en ai pas mais c'est bon, c'est pas indispensable.
- La levure ? Pff...  on s'en bat les couilles.
Et le gâteau au chocolat !
Quand on fait à manger à plusieurs, en famille ou autre,
je déteste ce mec qui goûte le plat directement dans la casserole.
Attends, juste avant de servir...
voilà.
Hum... un tout p'tit peu.
*Crache*
*Raclage de gorge* *Crache*
C'est bon. Là, tu peux servir.
Ni ce mec qui se vente tout le temps d'être bon vivant, généreux en matière grasse, et vas-y je met des trucs !
- On hésite pas sur l'huile, le sucre on y va.
Evidemment, le beurre ah, je te mets le bol ! Et re l'huile !
Plus rien à foutre ! Oh, et puis re-sucre, encore un peu, oh et puis un peu d'huile encore !
On est gourmand hein on est comme ça hein ? Il faut savoir manger.
- Tu laisses un peu mijoter à feu dou,x et on obtient...
*Roulement de tambour*
Bah une ordonnance pour un séjour à l'hôpital.
Ou alors, cette personne qui a cuisiné, bon ça c'est très sympa,
mais qui est totalement au taquet de savoir si son plat te plaît ou pas
- Aaalors ?
- Bah attends, j'ai pas encore goûté là.
- Ah, d'accord.
- C'est bon ?
- Bah là je goûte là. Là je... je goûte.
- Alors ?
- *Soupire* Oui c'est bon ! C'est super bon ! C'est délicieux.
-Bah t'as même pas goûté là.
*Bruit de ressort*
J'avoue que, dès qu'il faut cuisiner à plusieurs et que j'ai un peu la flemme,
j'ai encore une petite technique. C'est que je propose mon aide,
mais à la toute fin. Comme ça j'en fais le moins possible.
- Vous voulez que je vous aide ?
- Ah bah non, on a fini.
- Vas-y je vous aide vite fait y'a pas de souci ! *Bruit de triangle*
- Bon, on pourra dire qu'on l'a fait ensemble hein ? C'est un travail d'équipe !
Bon appétit ! Ne me dites pas merci, c'est trois fois rien !
Parfois, des amis me demandent de leur faire un plat typique de ma région natale.
C'est à dire le nord de la France, enfin les Haut de France...
'Fin ch'Nord quoi.
Mais dans le nord, il n'y a pas trente-six mille plats non plus. Ou je ne sais pas les faire.
Du coup ce que je peux leur proposer c'est éventuellement :
- Alors Dian, qu'est-ce que vous allez nous proposer aujourd'hui ?
- Bah chi teu veux faire des frites de barack à-l'-frites... De ch'nord.
Tu prends les frites comme cha, tu les mets dans l'ch'cornet, et ch'est tout.
- Ah ! D'accord, d'accord. Mais au niveau du plat...
- Bah ch'est tout.
D'ailleurs, les émissions de cuisine, je trouve ça hyper frustrant.
T'sais, ça a l'air ultra bon avec de magnifiques gros plans,
et toi tu regardes ça en mangeant un vieux truc merdique.
*Pleure*
*Musique triste*
Ces émissions de cuisine, j'ai l'impression qu'au fil des années elles ont un peu influencé les gens.
Des fois les gens quand ils t'invitent chez eux, ils se croient dans "Un dîner presque parfait".
Ils se prennent beaucoup trop la tête !
-  Hop hop hop hop hop hop ! Avant que vous dégustiez, je vous explique quand même, hein.
- Voilà, je vous ai fait un chutney de mangue braisé, revenu sur son coulis de coco sauvage
que j'ai fait revenir quelques minutes à feu doux
dans un bain marie à l'arménienne, voilà.
Après je me suis fais un petit peu plaisir..
Moi j'ai plus faim.
Au fait, si vous avez des restes et que vous ne savez pas quoi en faire,
bah au lieu de les jeter ou de gaspiller, il existe plein d'applications anti-gaspillage alimentaire.
Pensez-y, c'est pratique et écolo.
Bon voilà, moi je sais pas faire à manger, je sais juste m'alimenter et c'est déjà très bien, on va pas se plaindre.
En tout cas quand je regarde des vidéos de cuisine sur internet,
je me rends compte que je suis pas le seul au monde à ne pas savoir cuisiner.
Et ça, ça me rassure. Donc euh après tout...
*Rire gené* *Bruit de bouche*
Je sais pas comment conclure aller, CIAO !
*Crie*
*Crie de surprise*
*Cris de surprise*
*Rires*
- Oh la la les gars !
*Rire*